ce
bonsoir à tous le pays dépend bien
souvent du coeur de l'homme
il est petit si le coeur et petits et
grands c'est le cas des grands
bienvenue à tous
moi c'est céline vaucaire je suis
paysagiste je vais vous parler de la
transformation progressive de mon
cerveau d'occidental française au
contact des populations afro antillaise
en effet je ne suis pas originaire de la
martinique
je suis originaire d'un petit village de
la france hexagonale
oui j'ai changé merci j'ai changé à
travers mes cinq sens également la
communication avec les gens d'ici
vais vous parler surtout du côté
horizontale de la relation les cinq sens
d'abord la vue le quartier trénelle en
haut à gauche
c'est ça qui m'a le plus impressionné la
première fois que j'ai débarqué en
martinique
comme le disait yvon pas quitte ce matin
il parlait des quartiers populaires de
la ville de fort de france
qu'est ce que c'est le quartier trénelle
le quartier trénelle c'est d'abord un
des quartiers populaires de la ville de
fort de france et c'est d'avoir un morne
le monde désire tout en haut
un camp militaire et tout en bas une des
plus importante rivière de la martinique
la rivière madame alors ce qui m'a le
plus surpris effectivement ce sont ces
maisons collées les unes aux autres
aggloméré mais c'est surtout le fait que
je n'ai pas compris dans un premier
temps ce choc de culture alors quand on
ne comprend pas qu'est ce qu'on fait mon
chef
j'ai gravi ce morne et je suis allé voir
l'autre versant de l'autre côté de la
façade et là j'ai découvert une
population extraordinaire des maisons
coup de main c'est à dire le partage des
savoir faire
on travaille ensemble les faire ensemble
les soeurs les cousins et cousines les
autres tous nos savoir-faire regrouper
pour construire la maison on n'oublie
pas que ces quartiers
on était à l'initiative mise à
disposition par la mairie de fort de
france à l'époque
aimé césaire le maire qui a mis à
disposition ses quartiers afin que les
gens descendus des mornes puissent venir
habiter élever leur famille trouver un
toit
envoyer les enfants faire des études
cette mise à disposition et ce partage
ça veut dire que derrière la façade il y
a des valeurs les valeurs de partage de
solidarité et générosité
donc la vue l'ouïe bien sûr à travers
les sons laissons la musique antillaise
il ya pas si longtemps dans le parc aimé
césaire il y avait un hommage à marius
cultier et qui parlait il y a à la radio
de paysages sonores
je suis paysagiste ça m'a beaucoup
sensibilisé les quartiers il ya aussi
beaucoup de jeunes et les jeunes ce que
j'apprécie c'est qu'ils écoutent la
musique du pays
les musiques consciente et je rends
hommage aussi à kalach ya marius cultier
mais il ya aussi calage un son que
j'aime beaucoup ma ixon iloveyou my
phone ok merci pour ce qui m'a le
surpris c'est que effectivement les
jeunes d'ici ont de quoi écouter des
sons du pays
ça veut dire que ce que j'apprécie c'est
que nous sommes des êtres géographique
ce que nous voyons ce que nous entendons
ce que nous goûtons nous influence nous
sommes des êtres géographique nous
changeons au contact de ceux de nos cinq
sens je viens au goût
évidemment je lisais tout à l'heure dany
laferrière dans son dernier livre l'art
presque perdu de ne rien faire ou il
parle de l'art de manger une mangue ce
goût si particulier
edouard glissant également en parle
quand il est descendu avec sa maman à
l'âge d'un mois et demi
il dit que lui même il a ressenti
l'odeur des mangues alors qu'il était un
nourrisson
donc j'ai cherché j'ai cherché également
dans la littérature antillaise et j'ai
trouvé
j'ai cherché j'ai fait des recherches
sur les quartiers populaires de la ville
de fort de france et j'ai découvert
texaco un autre quartier de la ville de
fort de france mais qui est aussi le
titre d'un des romans les plus
prestigieux qui a fait le tour du monde
texaco de patrick chamoiseau qui est ni
plus ni moins prix boncourt merci ok
donc notre littérature notre musique nos
paysages voyage dans le monde entier
aujourd'hui nous vendons une image à
l'étranger
nous vendons qu'est ce que nous vendons
nous vendons notre slogan martinique île
aux fleurs
je suis paysagiste je suis sensible à ce
slogan est je voudrais que à travers
cette image on veut donner dans nos rues
et dans nos paysages
ce ça puisse refléter notre slogan notre
blason martinique île aux fleurs et y en
a il y en a des fleurs il y en a plus
belles les unes que les autres dans la
littérature antillaise
ne serait ce que dans la littérature
d'aimé césaire j'ai pu découvrir un
patrimoine botanique aimé césaire est un
botaniste et les pans du peuple et le
ciel d'acerra que sont les à serra en
haut à droite est assez rare
ce sont des orchidées les orchidées qui
pendent effectivement aux arbres et à
l'intérieur de cette petite fleur il ya
un petit personnage là il y en a deux
c'est un couple ces petits personnages
se sont ça évoque pour lui les pendus à
la période de l'esclavagé
le lynchage la littérature l'histoire la
culture culture nature culture sont liés
intimement liés et particulièrement dans
l'oeuvre d'aimé césaire l'alimentent us
cette fleur cette boule de fleurs petit
comme ça et qui à ses yeux représente la
coupe afro d'angela davis
voilà donc le toucher également à
travers la littérature
j'ai découvert une culture de résistance
résistance contre l'oppression
résistance contre la colonisation
jaccoulet un barrage j'ai accepté j'ai
adopté cette rage cette culture cette
résistance s'organise pouce à cette
pulpe cette culture cette résistance
s'organise sous les voies oui je
parlerai d'abord du serment du bois
caïman en bas à gauche en haïti comme
vous le savez cérémonie certes occulte
mais réunion des grands chefs
toussaint louverture boukman la
résistance s'organise également 1870
lemon de rivière pilote
l' incendie lumine à sophie les mains
les résistances s'organisent également
1822 les pitons du carbet
la résistance s'organise sous les bois
alors je reviens à mon métier paysagiste
ça me parle
ces plaintes et dans cette littérature
j'ai découvert effectivement cette lutte
cette lutte que nous recherchons tous
pour la liberté et moi paradoxalement
alors que je pouvait circuler partout
n'importe où
librement là où j'ai ressenti et le
moins de liberté c'est dans mon travail
mon travail de paysagistes pourquoi
parce que alors que je travaillais dans
un bureau d'études de génie civil alors
que je plantais déroute des trottoirs
des parkings
je comprenais pas comment je devais
lutter autant pour planter des arbres le
nom breton pliant martinique
je n'ai jamais réussi encore à
comprendre pourquoi c'est aussi
difficile de plaintes est alors que
complaintes et un trottoir on n'a pas de
problème c'était pas mon patron qui
m'ont empêché c'était quand on devait
présenter le projet et bien il y avait
des réticences parce que c'est toujours
la dernière roue de la charrette
les plantes hélas hélas brand fois hélas
parce que quand je suis au mans et rouge
je suis donc finalement depuis 12 ans
maintenant
originaire finalement du morne-rouge un
petit peu et quand je vois des grands
mères je félicite leur travail chaque
fois je les encourage parce que quand
elles sortent de la messe peut-être se
mettre à sa son corps produit avec leurs
talons on ne les voit plus elles sont
dans les buissons et puis y'a une
bouture de coolus
ici on l'appelle tapis monseigneur n'est
ce pas et il y en a toutes sortes de
variétés
la dame a dit je n'avais pas le verre
qui dit bravo madame maintenant vous
avez fait voyager les plantes
encore une fois pas plus tard qu'hier je
fais mon petit sport je vais en voiture
une voiture freine devant moi je vois un
monsieur sortir côté passager clic une
petites boutures de bégonias il y en a
plein et manouche le jeu dépasse la
voiture à une dame qui conduis je me dis
et la dame a envoyé chercher son bail
les dames sont infernales avec les
plaintes ensuite je retrouve la dame
nous allions au même endroit finalement
au morne-rouge au cap 21
elle n'allait pas se faire son sport
j'ai dit madame vous envoyer les autres
chercher vos affaires elle me dit oui
j'ai pris leur aux jeux j'avais le
blanche je n'avais pas le rose
je vous en prie c'est vrai et je gens
couraient ces gens là parce que le
bégonia tout le monde sait que ça
reprend super facilement c'est pas du
vol 1 on est bien d'accord
et bien moi je félicite toutes les
grands mères
ici ils font ce travail et qui contribue
à cultiver leur jardin parce que ce que
j'ai pu remarquer c'est que
effectivement dans la nature il ya cette
diversité
mais cette grande diversité c'est dans
les jardins des jambes qui lie à des
collectionneurs fabuleux ici en
martinique et je les félicite et je les
encourage donc comme je ne pouvais pas
forcément plantés dans les projets j'ai
planté évidemment chez moi et puis à
l'extérieur de chez moi comme les grands
mères le fond et j'ai pris donc cette
force cette force des grandes personnes
et puis j'ai circulé encore et puis là
j'ai découvert également la culture de
l'art et la culture de la rue parce que
combien de noms de quartiers les
quartiers d'aimé césaire bas maternité
rue de la citronnelle rue du pata gambe
rue du patchouli
où sont les plantes alors je dis
plantons du vétiver au quartier vétiver
à case-pilote des balata au quinté
balata d acajou en acajou ou françois
des flamboyants à la cité des
flamboyants et c'était un planton nos
arbres de vie il respectons les noms des
rues parce que les noms des rues nous
représente représente notre histoire
les plantes font partie de l'histoire
les plantes ont voyagé la rue est à nous
et je reprendrai les paroles du groupe
iam ça vient de la rue
le style et l'élégance les techniques et
les danses cherche pas tu sais d'où ça
vient ça vient de la rue
alors je vous dis à tous plantons nos
arbres de vie ici récit
plantons nos arbres de vie par tous
collectivement ensemble
plantons partout n'hésitons pas
librement
la rue est à nous c'est notre nature
allons-y gaiement
merci à tous